enfin je vais finir avec un très rapide
panorama son changement climatique s'est
très vite par julien raciale question
voilà pas bon évoluer des émissions de
co2 planétaire discriminés par énergie
jusqu'à la présentation vous aurez le
temps d'y revenir
voilà à quoi ressemble les éditions par
source
aujourd'hui de commentaires là dessus si
j'additionne les émissions des centrales
à charbon et des centrales à gaz je
pense que 25% des émissions planétaires
c'est à dire presque deux fois les
émissions du transport
donc si je prends le paie quand vous
construisez une centrale à charbon en
weppes 40 ans ramène donc aujourd'hui au
niveau mondial
l'enjeu central de la négociation climat
c'est empêcher les gens penseraient les
centrales au charbon et savoureux
central de la négociation qui va
empêcher les gens d'acheter des voitures
surplus d'essence avec dedans alors à
tourner l'industrie automobile et les
gens qui ont fait ça sans plaire à
l'économie des matériels donc le lac
ainsi statut et en a claqué matic un
truc aussi sur lesquels il faut insister
c'est que l'activité agricole au sens
large puisque l'essentiel de la
déforestation en vise à obtenir des
terres agricoles
c'est à tiers des émissions en termes
concernés j'y reviendrai ça c'est bien
des questions c'est juste pour dire que
la variation qu'on est susceptible
d'infliger au système climatique juste
simple commenté quand même parce que ça
sera important
la variation dans les susceptible
d'infliger
climatique c'est à dire de l'ordre de
quelques degrés en un siècle est
totalement hors norme comparé à la
variation naturelle du système alors je
vais prendre deux organismes deux êtres
vivants un poisson rouge et dont le
poisson rouge
je sais pas si certains d'entre vous
utilisez de tuer le poisson rouge
d'enfants de cette manière ça marche pas
vous ne m'aidez dans l'eau très froide y
survit vous mettez dans votre h audition
dit il à un organisme qui est fait pour
que une variation de sa température
interne quelques degrés contre foot qui
se porte très bien merci
donc si cet organisme vous lui infligez
délibérément une variation de quelques
degrés de sa température interne il est
fait pour ça il s'en fout on prenait un
être humain lui infliger l'aria sion d1
température interne de quelques degrés
ou la save a réuni 0 3 degré parloir de
température interne mais des fois un don
vous lui infligez les variations de
température à terre quelques degrés
l'intérieur parce qu'il est pas fait
pour ça eh bien le système climatique
n'est pas fait pour rester stables avec
qui parler seconde de sa température de
quelques degrés en un siècle n'est pas
fait pour ça il est fait pour rester
stables avec les variations de sa
température
quelques fractions de degrés en quelques
milliers d'années ça il sait faire
quelques d'orientation qui sait pas
faire quelques degrés de variation de la
température c'est l'équivalent d'une des
glaciations quand on est passé du
maximum de la dernière ère glaciaire
ruiz plus froid a aujourd'hui la planète
de se réchauffer que de 5,2 si vous
devez retenir à shief 1,5 sur le
changement climatique en décidant quand
on passe d'un monde recouvert de
glaciers sur la scandinavie la belgique
ressemble ou d'or de la sibérie actuelle
honoré sidéris actuelle au monde moderne
l'élévation de température de l'année
derrière ce jusqu'au 29
juste quand je vous ai dit ça parce que
vous êtes à peu près tout dit sur le
changement climatique
c'est à dire que 5 degré de variation en
un siècle vous engendre chaotique
violent très vert ingérable un jardin
juste une affaire de plus en plus en
moins je prends toi
la cance de vos ennemis ou non tout est
désorganisé tout parce que c'est un
changement d'une ampleur absolument
massive la dernière fois que c'est
arrivé notre espèce les 5 millions
d'individus
j'espère la lettre sac à dos n'avait pas
de revendications sociales est mort hier
à temps vous appliquez le même genre
plaisanterie à une humanité sédentaires
de sédentaires pardon de 7 9 milliards
d'individus qui vous pouvez pas les
déranger
il est absolument évident comme ça
attisera des conflits à peu près partout
et si j'avais le temps vous expliquer
leurs poils au printemps arabe et
terminant climatique qui est déjà
extrêmement fort dès quand on fait les
gros yeux j'étais l'arabe et j'avais un
petit truc sur lequel je reviendrai
éventuellement